COMING UP.
IN THE MEANTIME FORSBERGT OFF F.
DUMPED IN AND OUT OF THE NET IS
MERZLIKINS ON A DELAYT OF THE N
WALKING THEMSELVES SLOWLY INTO
GLOVE.IC CENTERING PASS
WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE LAINE
ZACH WERENSKI WILL HAND
NOT A GOOD ANGLE BUT HE NEARLY
CATCHES THE FAR SIDE.
THAT IT BACK IN
FRONT.
HOLDEN UP WITH THEO GO AND YOU
GOT TO GUT THIS OUT.
SO FAR SCARLSSON.
LONG PASS UP FOR DOMI.
IT IS OVER HIS STICK.
ORES!
[Horn sounds]
TYLER ENNIS TIPS IT HOME!
72.
AND REAL GOOD DEFENCEMAN LIKE
CHABOT CAN CONTROL THE PACE OFL
HIS CONFIDENCE BACK WAS
PHYSICAL.
D.J. SMITH HAD A LONG TALK WITH
HIM AND YOU HAVE GOT TO PLAY LO.
LAINE TO
PLAYED IT OFF FOR BROWN AND
GAVRIKOV, DUMPED IT BAC
AND HERE WE GO WITH PERIOD
NUMBER TWO. WRONG WITH
THAT.
>> John: MERZLIKINS WILLHAVE.
THIS IS A LONG STRETCH
TIERNEY CHASING HIM.
CHRIS TIERNEY
ZAITSEV RIGHT IN FRONT OF HIM
AND BATTLING WITH DANFOSLOWED U.
DEAN  MOVE.
RIGHT UPO HIS STICK IS OFF THE
ICE.
UP IN THE CHEST AREA OF ROSLOVIC
.
ICING WAVED OFF SO MERZLIKINS
WILL SETAKES A HIT FROM PARKER
KELLY.
TIERNEY BRINGS IT IN FOROR
IT CAN DO FORESHADOWING.
FATHER WEARING 18.
HE SCORES WHEN HE'S 18.
HOW ABOUTRLSSON, ONE HAND ON TH.
AND HE'LL KNOCK IT TT ANOTHER
HERE.
REAL GOOD SKATER AND LAINE BEEN
ALL OVER THE ICE MAKING GOOD
TKACHUK HAVE GOT TO GET IN TO
PULL THIS THTH
>> Garry: NORRIS GOING TO WIN
THIS DRAW.
HE WINS IT TO A,